Hallo Stefan.
So wir stehen vor dem Salon.
Sehr schlechtes Wetter, gutes Wetter, um Podcasts zu hören und sie aufzunehmen. Jetzt läuft gerade die Impfpflicht Debatte. Wir wissen noch nicht, wie sie ausgeht. Ist aber für uns auch nicht so relevant, denke ich. Und wenn man ein bisschen unterwegs ist, das war ich ja in den vergangenen Wochen, dann relativieren sich selbstverständlich auch die großen politischen Debatten über Corona, sondern man erlebt einfach, was funktioniert im Alltag und was nicht. So saß ich in Köln in einem Café und da galt die 3G-Regel. Und die Kellnerin kam offenbar aus dem Urlaub wieder oder war relativ neu und trat an einen Nachbartisch und sagte dann zu der Dame, die da saß, ja, ich muss jetzt die 3G-Regel kontrollieren. Und dann zeigte die Dame ihren Impfausweis und dann sagte die Kellnerin, ja, aber sie sind ja noch nicht genesen. Und dann, ja, wie genesen, ich bin ja geimpft. Und dann dachte sie, man muss alles sein. Und dann denkt man sich, ja, wo kriegt man so schnell noch eine Infektion her? Ja, und es schritt dann aber eine andere Kellnerin ein und klärte das Missverständnis dann auf. Dann ging ich tatsächlich raus, stand an der Ampel. Dann kam ein sehr alter, offenbar sehr verwirrter Mann an, sah, dass ich meine Maske einpackte und sagte, das ist ja auch der Wahnsinn, dass wir das jetzt hier seit zwei Jahren machen. Und jetzt dreht noch der Putin durch. Also große Verwirrung auf der Welt. Aber dann auch vielleicht eine gewisse Klarheit. Wir werden ja heute über ein Buch sprechen, das sagt, man muss sehr vorsichtig sein mit der Leistungsgesellschaft und der Chancengleichheit und auch mit so einer Rede von intelligent und dumm. Und die einen, die können die komplexen Welten verstehen und die anderen, die sind ja viel zu schlicht dafür. Ich will eine Anekdote noch aus Hamburg erzählen. Da war ich ja auch und ging dort die Straße entlang, musste sie dann überqueren, hatte dann also so ein paar Sekunden mehr, die man mithört bei einem Gespräch. Da standen zwei Frauen so Mitte 50, Ende 50. Auf dem Bordstein und unterhielten sich über Corona. Ich bekam das so mit und die Frau erzählte, ja, mein Sohn hat es ja jetzt auch, aber der hatte so gut wie nichts, nur ein Schnupfen. Und dann sagte die Frau, und jetzt muss auch mal gut sein. Und das fand ich ganz interessant, denn man könnte jetzt ja ganz arrogant darüber sprechen und sagen, ja, Entschuldigung mal, haben Sie denn die Inzidenz nicht gesehen? Haben Sie dann nicht die Oxford-Studie gelesen, die Lauterbach gestern noch empfohlen hat? Nein, das hat sie natürlich alles nicht gemacht. Aber sie hat ja einen Erfahrungsraum, in dem sie sich bewegt und der ihr jetzt gezeigt hat, man kann sich impfen, man kann sich entsprechend eine Zeit lang schützen, wenn man noch nicht geimpft ist. Wenn man geimpft ist und es bekommt, dann ist es, wie ihr Sohn offenbar beweist, gar nicht so dramatisch. Und dann kommt sie zu dem Schluss, jetzt muss auch mal gut sein. In gewisser Weise hat sie die komplexen Dimensionen von Corona absolut wahrgenommen, macht das nicht über einen fachwissenschaftlichen Diskurs, aber kommt eigentlich zu einem sehr wissenschaftlichen Schluss, möchte ich sagen, dass sie sagt, jetzt muss ja auch mal gut sein.
Ja, genau, das war das Versprechen der Impfung. Dann kann eben auch mal gut sein. Ich bin, wie soll ich sagen, ich bin überhaupt nicht gespannt oder interessiert, was die heute im Bundestag machen. Ich habe heute morgen so gesehen, Ankündigung, Live-Tickerei von dem, was im Bundestag gesagt wird, Null Antrieb da drauf zu klicken. Ich finde, es ist auch relativ zügig klar geworden jetzt, wie die CDU das torpedieren will und so. Und dann die auch die Regierung vorführen. Wahrscheinlich wird es gar keine Mehrheiten geben heute. Schon allein, weil Olaf Scholz sich so festgelegt hatte, wir bräuchten die und die CDU, die ihn da vorführen kann. Aber mal sehen, das kann man ja abwarten.
Ja, für Lauterbach wird es ganz entscheidend sein, dass er wenigstens irgendetwas der Tätergemeinde darbieten kann. Denn inzwischen ist das ja doch sehr lachhaft, dieses Ganze agieren. Und ich würde sagen, dass die SPD, ich wage mich so weit vor, eigentlich eine ganz gute Verhandlungsmasse hat gerade. Also ich würde ja der FDP, wenn es jetzt um diese ganzen Streichungen bei sozialen Leistungen geht, ein Deal anbieten. Wir liefern euch Lauterbach, das heißt also, wir setzen ihn ab und nennen jemand anders als Minister. Und dafür aber müsst ihr mehr soziale Gerechtigkeit zulassen. Das heißt, Lindner muss den Geldtopf öffnen. Das wäre eigentlich ganz geschickt, denn mit Twitter hat sich ja Lauterbach jetzt auch so ein bisschen überworfen, beziehungsweise die Twitter-Gemeinde hält nicht mehr treu zu ihm. Insofern ist es auch nicht mehr so wichtig. Und vielleicht würde das die Gemüter beruhigen und würde dann auch ein bisschen einem Kubicki und so weiter den Wind aus den Segel nehmen.
Also mal sehen, ich finde es auf der einen Seite schon auch ein bisschen traurig, aber eben auch beeindruckend, wie sehr Lauterbach jetzt gerade unter die Räder kommt. Auch der Deutschlandfunk hat gestern so Instagram-Kacheln gemacht, bei denen sich eigentlich nur noch lustig gemacht haben über Lauterbach. Es war ganz, also diese Art von Humor, auch der Albernheit habe ich so beim Deutschlandfunk noch gar nicht wahrgenommen, aber dann plötzlich ploppte das da so auf. Ob man solche Deals machen kann, wir liefern euch Lauterbach, also das kann man ja nun so nicht kommunizieren, aber man kann das intern natürlich machen.
Das war nur eine Beratung, das war nur jetzt für mich Gratis-Politik-Beratung, die ich hier geleistet habe. Also, liebe SPD, wenn ihr, dann könnt ihr jetzt in die Hinterzimmer gehen, dann könnt ihr das machen und dann muss man irgendwie natürlich Lauterbach auch dazu bringen. Das wird wahrscheinlich das Schwierigste sein.
Genau, irgendwie organisiert werden, dass es auch zum Vollzug kommt. Und naja.
Aber Corona hat doch einen Vorteil, also jetzt wo es noch so ein bisschen da ist. Ich war in der Kölner Philharmonie in einem Kammerkonzert und für gewöhnlich ist es so, ja du tust es auch schon husten, nämlich für gewöhnlich ist es so, dass das Konzert verhustet wird.
Genau, ich habe, also für die Hörer habe ich es gerade rausgeschnaltet, das Husten meint. Und jetzt muss ich auch schon wieder trinken und ich merke schon, ich brauche heute immer eine halbe Sekunde länger um anzusetzen und dann springst du schon wieder rein. Denn ich wollte noch eine zweite, also bevor du aus vom Husten im Publikum, es gibt irgendwie eine neue Krankheit. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Ich kam am Freitag in den Kindergarten und man sagte mir, hier haben heute elf Kinder Fieber gehabt. Ihr war nicht dabei. Zack, ein Tag später zu Hause 38 Grad, 39 Grad. Wir haben es gar nicht verstanden. Wir haben noch mehrere Kinder hier im Haus. Zack, maximale Temperatur, die wir gemessen hatten am Wochenende, waren 40, 8 Grad. Ohne besorgniserregendes Leid dahinter, sondern nur Müdigkeit und Schwäche. Es hat mich auch ein bisschen erwischt. Und gestern hieß es dann, ja, wir fragen auch mal beim Gesundheitsamt nach, was es ist. Es sind gerade alle krank. Also wir haben es irgendwie.
Kein Corona, sondern etwas anderes.
Es ist kein Corona, jedenfalls nichts, was sich schnelltestmäßig nachweisen lässt. Es fühlt sich auch nicht an, wie man immer sagte, dass es Corona ist. Ich weiß nicht, wie sich Corona anfühlt. Ging bisher an mir spurlos vorüber und an allen anderen in der Familie auch. Auch durch Impfung der Kinder und so weiter. Aber dieses Ding schlägt einem so richtig zwei Tage lang KO. Also mein Akku war auch bei minus drei Prozent. Ich konnte nicht mal eine sehr freundliche Videochat-Einladung annehmen, die ich sehr gerne angenommen hätte, um so ein bisschen zu plaudern. Ich war einfach richtig KO. Und ich finde es irgendwie crazy, dass wir auf der einen Seite so eine Infektionskrankheit haben, die jetzt irgendwie mit R12, keine Ahnung, kann man ja nicht mehr genau messen, weil es sind ja schon viele geimpft und so weiter. Die Inzidenzen sind jedenfalls hoch. Und dann kommt so was Neues, das wirklich flächendeckendes Fieber. Also ich rede hier von mehr als die Hälfte der Kindergartenkinder gleichzeitig. Wir hatten hier am Wochenende Besuch. Noch am nächsten Morgen nach der Abreise. Zack, wir liegen so da nieder. Es ist gar nichts zu machen. Es ist wirklich eine Krankheit, die so schnell plötzlich über uns kam, dass es irgendwie, dass ich in zwei Wochen gibt es wahrscheinlich so Texte. Da ging voll die Welle durch und so. Aber jetzt, wo gerade Corona so rum ist und so und ja, ich weiß, es sind jetzt nur so zwei, drei Tage und ich leide also, ich leide immer besonders unter solchen Krankheiten, weil ich ansonsten nie krank bin. Und dann schlägt sich das bei mir immer gleich so ein bisschen durch. Aber ich will das auch nur sagen, weil ich mich trotzdem wahnsinnig freue, dass ich heute diesen Podcast machen, weil ich selten, vielleicht nie, keine Ahnung, ich will es nicht übertreiben, aber ich trage seit 15 Jahren eine Frage mit mir rum, was es mit dem Neokalvinismus auf sich hat, von Gott aus erwählt. Was heißt das eigentlich? Gibt es dieses Konzept noch? Schleicht sich das so ein, obwohl wir gar nicht mehr an Gott glauben? Also so eine Schicksalshaftigkeit zwischen ist es echt nur Zufall? Nein, da muss doch was dahinterstecken. Ach ja, ich stecke ja dahinter und so. Also so eine Idee von irgendwie bin ich doch schuld an meinem Schicksal. Warum bin ich eigentlich nicht in Nigeria geboren und leider Hunger den ganzen Tag? Warum freue ich mich, dass wir eine deutsche Grenze haben? Wohnen hier die Guten und da die Schlechten? Oder wie ist dieser Spruch, uns geht's gut, weil wir die Guten sind? Ja, uns geht's gut, wir sind die Guten. Also da stecken so psychologische Konzepte dahinter, die wir nie so richtig austreiben können, das sagt der Sandel auch. Und ich bin zum einen intellektuell so ein bisschen angeregt darum, dass ich in diesem zweiten Kapitel das einfach mal so nachlesen konnte von jemanden wirklich sehr klugen. Auf der anderen Seite hat dieses Buch, wie wir ja besprachen, so eine gewisse Gravitation, weil es einfach die Bettlektüre unseres Kanzlers ist. Und das beruhigt mich auf so eine tiefe Art, denn auch wenn wir jetzt einen absolut der Realität ausgelieferten Kanzler haben, der erstmal wirklich Schritt für Schritt und so weiter, schwingt doch im Hintergrund eine Ideologie mit, mit der ich mich, ich will nicht sagen, voll und ganz einverstanden erkläre, sondern deren Fundamente und Fragen ich auch als wirklich super relevant ansehe, die genau jetzt gestellt werden müssen. Und dieses Buch besprechen wir heute. Deswegen sitze ich hier zwar etwas ermattet und finde es auch Wahnsinn, wenn du wieder erzählst, du treibst dich gerade in der echten Welt rum und dann kommt eine Kellnerin und fragst, sind sie denn noch nicht genesen? Was ist denn hier los? Infizieren sie sich mal. Also da kommt ja auch die ganze Realität in ihrem bizarren Sein da zusammen.
Ja, aber die Begegnung mit der Realität sind ja mitunter sehr schön, nur um das noch mit dem Husten abzuschließen. Ich war in der Philharmonie in Köln und habe festgestellt, es ist so herrlich ruhig. Natürlich. Die Leute müssen ja noch Maske tragen, aber das ist nicht der eigentliche Grund, sondern wer heute hustet, macht sich ja verdächtig, Corona in die Welt zu tragen. Also reißen sich alle zusammen. Sonst kann man Konzerten so, nee, nee, nee, nee, die machen jetzt mal das, was vernünftig ist, dass man nicht hustet. Man kann zwei Stunden irgendwo sitzen, wenn man nicht wirklich krank ist, ohne zu husten. Und wenn man mal sieht, wann Leute husten, dann sind es vor allem die langsamen Sätze. Das heißt, sie halten es nicht aus, sich mit der Musik zu konfrontieren und dann fangen sie aus Verlegenheit an zu husten. Sie haben sich mit anderen Worten nicht unter Kontrolle. Und das finde ich doch ganz schön, dass man momentan diese Übergangsphase nutzen sollte. Momentan wird noch nicht gehusst. Ich hoffe, dass es nicht so schnell zurückkommt, aber es wird bestimmt wieder zurückkommen. Und man kann jetzt momentan sehr gut klassische Konzerte genießen, weil die Leute sich wahnsinnig zusammenreißen. Das war jetzt für mich ganz großartig. Und ich möchte noch darauf hinweisen, es gibt noch ein klassisches Highlight in diesem Monat. Morgen erscheint die neue CD des Pianisten Sokolov, der größte Pianist, den wir zurzeit haben. Und morgen kommt seine neue CD. Und er muss auch unter Corona wahnsinnig gelitten haben. Das würde mich mal interessieren, denn er nimmt nie im Tonstudio auf. Das heißt, das sind nur Mitschnitte von Konzerten. Er geht nie ins Tonstudio, sondern immer nur live Konzerte. Gebt auch so gut wie keine Interviews, macht nur diese Konzerte mit sehr vielen Zugaben. Dass der so lange dann auch nicht spielen durfte, das wird sicherlich für ihn ein großes Problem gewesen sein. Aber wir haben jetzt zumindest aus der Corona-Zeit von einem Konzert einen Mitschnitt, glaube ich, ist das. Oder vielleicht ist es auch von etwas früher. Jedenfalls erscheint diese Serie, da bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt drauf, weil das so großartig ist. Und ich kann nur dazu animieren, mehr ins Konzert wiederzugehen.
Richtig, sehr guter Hinweis noch. Gestern wurde in Frankfurt das MoMem eröffnet. Das ist das Museum of Modern Electronic Music. Und wie man das so macht, gab es da eine große Party davor. Sven Feld ist aufgetreten. Klar, man hört immer noch, dass er Musik macht und so. Aber irgendwie denkt man ja doch, ist er eigentlich auch schon 70 oder so? Das ist ja sozusagen Anfangszeit-Love-Parade in den 90ern oder 80ern vielleicht sogar. Und ich habe es natürlich verpasst, weil krank. Bestärkte mich aber einmal mehr wieder, dass jetzt, sobald ich meine kleine was auch immer Erkältung überstanden habe, doch die Post-Corona-Zeit beginnt und wir das Rummeln vor der EZB dann auch hier beginnen werden. Ich werde alle auf dem Laufenden halten, die sich dafür interessieren. Interessanterweise wurde gleich eine 250 Euro große Fernsehpodcast-Präsentation genau mit diesem Wunsch verknüpft. Abhängen vor der EZB finde ich gut. Dann habe ich mir gedacht, wenn das so viel wert ist, dann wird es natürlich eingerichtet. Also alle zwei Wochen oder so kann man sich jetzt darauf einstellen. Irgendeine Mittwoche oder Donnerstag geht es dann einfach los. Und damit ist dann dieses Kapitel hoffentlich auch soweit abgeschlossen. Denn solche kleinen Erkältungen, die nimmt man sportlich mit, wenn man weiß, dann geht es aber auch weiter. Und nur weil man selber kurz krank ist, steht nicht die ganze Welt still. Das ist auch ein sehr gutes Gefühl.
Die Erfahrungen mit der Wirklichkeit lassen sich natürlich auch rückbinden wieder an das, was man liest. Und du hast ja jetzt schon das Buch eingeleitet. Und ich darf auch sagen, ich bin begeistert und ich bin vor allem überrascht. Denn in meiner marxistischen Arroganz habe ich natürlich gedacht, na ja, das ist so ein sozialdemokratisches Buch. Da wird noch mal so ein bisschen vom Wert der Arbeit geredet und mehr doch nicht. Und nein, nein, nein, es ist wirklich ein philosophisch hochinteressantes Werk, das auch du hast schon angesprochen, viele andere Grundsätzlichkeiten uns klar werden lässt, hat mich in vielen Dingen auch überrascht hinsichtlich der eigentlichen Dimension dieses Leistungsimperatiefs, den wir komplett internalisiert haben. Und die Wirklichkeit trifft dann auf dieses Buch. Wenn ich in Dresden bin, da war ich auch letzten Samstag. Und da war eine Veranstaltung mit vielen jungen Leuten, die sich über Demokratie und Wirtschaft und Klimawandel und so weiter informiert haben. Und ich war da quasi so als Experte, als Mitdiskutant. Vorab aber kamen die US-Konsulin für Mitteldeutschland, die in Leipzig sitzt, die eigentlich so da war, um so ein bisschen schön Wetter zu machen. Und dann war aber doch interessant zu sehen. Und es waren auch Hörer des Neuen Zwanziger Podcasts und von Wohlstein für alle, die dann auch Fragen stellten. Und es war sehr interessant, dass erst jemand fragte, naja, sie sprechen jetzt über Spaltung der Gesellschaft. Wie ist es denn mit der Ungleichheit? Na und dann kamen sie ja mit, ja, für uns ist es ganz wichtig. Wir müssen Diversity und nicht immer nur alte weiße Männer und so was. Und sofort kam danach ein Hörer, der auch uns hört, der sie dann so ein bisschen grillte und sagte, naja, sie haben ja jetzt die Frage, weil es das gar nicht beantwortet. Sie schieben das ja jetzt einfach auf ein bisschen Identitätspolitik und Chancengleichheit. Aber eigentlich geht es doch hier um eine ökonomische Ungleichheit. Da ist dann nicht nur die Frage, haben wir genug Diversität? Und dann kam sie sofort ins Schwimmen. Und es waren dann doch sehr viele junge Leute, die sehr kritische Fragen gestellt haben, bis hin zu dann, wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass Amerika so mit Assange umgeht. Also das war sehr, sehr schön zu beobachten, dass man diese Wohlfühl, wir müssen mal alle wieder als Gesellschaft zusammenstehen, Haltung überhaupt von den Jungen nicht so akzeptiert sah, zumindest von denen, die da Fragen gestellt haben. Während der Moderator so im typischen Sound of Peace-Alter, der hätte das auch noch sein können, immer so sagte, ja das ist ja toll, die jungen Leute und so. Aber eigentlich hatte die natürlich für dumm verkaufen, auch mit ihnen so gesprochen, als seien sie eigentlich 12 Jahre alt. Und das war sehr, sehr schön zu sehen. Und eigentlich waren da schon ganz viele Fragen aufgeworfen, die dann Sandel beantwortet. Also eine Abkehr von der Leistungsgesellschaft. Da würde jetzt erstmal jeder intuitiv sagen, ja wie, aber das ist doch gerade gut. Wir wollen doch nicht, dass Privilegien vererbt werden. Aber was ist eigentlich, wenn man die Leistungsgesellschaft konsequent zu Ende denkt? Und das tut Sandel. Ich bin auch sehr begeistert und ich glaube, wir können jetzt wunderbar darüber sprechen. Aber sag noch, was hast du uns weiteres mitgebracht?
Ja, weil es passt. MacKenzie Scott verschenkt ja Geld. Sie ist die Ex-Frau von Jeff Bezos. Es ist kein Text von März, sondern von August 21. Aber es passt einfach wunderbar, denn sehr viele Stiftungen, Organisationen, die sich um irgendetwas kümmern, bekommen einfach E-Mails, in denen steht, wir möchten ihnen gern 10 Millionen Dollar schenken. Wohin sollen wir das Geld schicken? Dann antworten sie nicht drauf, weil sie denken, sie werden veralbert. Und stellt sich aber raus, nein, so verschenkt sie das Geld. Man kann bei ihr keinen Antrag stellen. Man tritt nie mit ihr in Kontakt, sondern man bekommt einfach E-Mails, wo drin steht, wir möchten ihnen Geld schenken. Und dann muss man darauf reagieren. Dieses Geld wird zweckfrei einfach nur zur Verfügung gestellt, damit die Leute auch am Wochenende mal wieder frei nehmen können, neben ihrer ganzen ehrenamtlichen Arbeit. Und es handelt sich um mehr Geld als die Bill Gates-Stiftung und die Ford-Stiftung zusammen verschenkt oder vergibt. Die machen das ja nach so harten Regularien.
Muss man ohne Spam-Ordner nachschauen.
Genau. Und sich dieses Konzept mal anzuschauen, ist der pure Wahnsinn. Geothermie. Geothermie, wir haben es letztes Mal auch ein bisschen kurz drüber gesprochen, lässt sich derzeit nur für Wärme nutzen und auch nur zum Heizen. Wenn man so einen niedrigen Temperaturkreislauf hat, also Bodenheizung und sowas, wo man nicht viel Temperaturunterschied braucht, um das zu erwärmen. Jetzt ein Durchbruch. Man schafft es tatsächlich mit Mikrowellen jetzt tiefer zu bohren, da wo es richtig heiß wird. Und wir nähern uns dann so den Temperaturen der Sonnenoberfläche, sodass man auch Energie, also nicht nur Wärme, sondern es auch zur Energieerzeugung nutzen kann. Unser auch mit Lieblingsautor Max Chefkin, wir kennen ihn als Peter Thiel Biograf, hat sich Gedanken gemacht darüber, warum Elon Musk zehn Prozent von Twitter gekauft hat. Der Gedankengang ist glaube ich ganz wichtig und auch einer, der unter den vielen, die das jetzt irgendwie thematisieren, noch mal erwähnenswert ist. Und wie angekündigt, der ehemalige afghanische Finanzminister. Er ist Übertreiber in Washington, lebt dort und fährt jeden Tag am Headquarter der World Bank und des Internationalen Währungsfonds vorbei. Hat mit denen noch Geschäfte gemacht vor einem Jahr und versucht jetzt, das eine oder andere Goodie rauszuholen, wenn das schafft, in den nächsten zwei Stunden 50 Fahrten zu machen oder sowas. Also nennt sich, das ist eine ganz dramatische Geschichte, die die Washington Post dann noch mal aufgeschrieben hat.
Ich habe einen unglaublichen Roman, der aus Brasilien stammt. Er ist von Tatiana Sadam-Levy, Vista Chinesa. Es ist der Roman über eine Vergewaltigung. Dieser Roman beruht auf wahrer Begebenheit. Und es ist so unfassbar. Wer jetzt einen harten Realismus einfach nur erwartet, der wird das nicht finden, sondern es ist tatsächlich der Versuch, literarisch damit umzugehen. Und ich habe beim Lesen meinen Körper anders erlebt. Das ist etwas, was nur ganz selten Literatur schafft. Großartig. Dann ein Text, ich habe schon angekündigt über den Herrenanzug und warum er irrelevanter wird, woran man das auch ablesen kann.
What?
Ja, dann einen Text über Amazon. Wir wissen, da gibt es jetzt eine Gewerkschaft neuerdings, die gegründet wurde. Aber man entwickelt gerade ein sehr eigenartiges Chatprogramm mit sehr neusprechartigen Formationen, die sich da bilden. Dann fragen wir uns ja, was macht eigentlich diese russische Elite gerade? Die waren ja nicht immer alle Putin-Verehrer. Und da gibt es eine ganz lange investigative Story zu. Da ist eine Journalistin, die vorher bei der BBC war, die viele Kontakte offenbar noch hat, um zu erfahren, was denken die eigentlich gerade darüber. Und auch die Frage, sind die Sanktionen wirksam in unserem Sinne? Also was wir eigentlich damit erreichen wollen. Und ich kann schon mal spoilern. Nee, ich glaube dann doch nicht. Also das ist ein hochinteressanter Text jedenfalls, den man sich stellen muss. Und dann habe ich noch einen fünften Text. Da stellt sich eine Stadtsoziologe in die Frage, wie wir jetzt eigentlich Räume und Städte wahrnehmen. Und bleibt es bei Homeoffice bei diesem Trend oder eher doch nicht? Und das ist auch etwas, was, glaube ich, noch mal aus einer soziologischen Perspektive hochinteressant ist, wie wir Räume wahrnehmen. Und ich darf noch auf eine Sache vorher vor dem Salon hinweisen. Und zwar habe ich gerade einen, weil wir ja viel über den Krieg gesprochen haben der letzten Folge, und das machen wir jetzt nur ein bisschen. Ich habe gerade bei Twitter einen Tweet gelesen von Patrick Breitenbach. Der ist ja auch beim Soziopod. Und der schreibt, ich bin ein Feigling. Ich würde versuchen, meine Familie einzupacken und so schnell es geht, mein Vaterland zu verlassen. Krieg schluckt Leben. Ich werde nicht als Held im Dreck sterben, nur weil ich andere wie mich getötet habe und die Kriegslenker in ihren Palästen hocken. Ich finde das sehr schön. Der Thread geht dann noch ein bisschen länger. Kann man nachlesen bei Twitter. Und es erinnerte mich an einen Text, den ich auch gelesen habe, den verlinken wir mal mit, bei Spiegel Online von Thomas Fischer, diesem Anwalt, der einen sehr, sehr langen Text geschrieben hat, der natürlich auch da keinen Gefangenen macht, um es so zu formulieren, und der damit endet, dass er sagt, ich muss abschließend zugeben, dieser Text steht im Verdacht, das Gedankenverbrechen der Relativierung zu verwirklichen. Denn er vergleicht mal, wie reagieren wir eigentlich auf andere Krisen und Kriege. Es ist, so meine ich, kein Auftrag der Ehre, für das Vaterland zu sterben. Ich traure um jeden, dem die Sehnsuchtsstrategen diesen Ehrenkranz aufs Grab werfen. Menschen im Krieg sind Verfügungsmassen fremder Interessen. Das ist nicht Ehre, sondern Elend. Sehr, sehr guter Text, kann ich auch empfehlen. Das wollte ich noch vor dem Salon gesagt haben. Dann freuen wir uns aber, wenn wir uns gleich hinter der Steady Paywall oder hinter der Apple Paywall wiedersehen.
Also diesen Text, den du gerade noch mal final rezitiert hast, der ist wirklich sehr gut. Der war bei mir auch in der engen Auswahl. Ich habe ihn dann doch wieder rausgenommen. Man kennt ja so Thomas Fischer. Der hat ja immer so diese Art und Richtung geschrieben. Als er damals bei Zeit das nicht mehr machte, da habe ich schon Befürchtungen gehabt, jetzt macht das einfach so bei Spiegel oder wo auch immer. Ich bin gerade, ich merke es an mir, getriggert, hin und hergerissen. Ich bin aber auch nicht ganz auf Augenhöhe mit meiner von mir an selbst einbrauchten Leistungsfähigkeit, der ich ansonsten immer, ich habe zum Beispiel heute oben zurückgelehnt, mir das einfach mal ausgedruckt, was ich mir zu Sandel rausgeschrieben habe. Aber eine Sache will ich doch noch sagen, so aus Verwunderung. Wir haben jetzt im Februar und im März auf eine Art und Weise über den Krieg in der Ukraine gesprochen, der, wie du es eben auch antwortest, so eine etwas konsistente Art hat, nämlich zu sagen, Krieg ist nicht gut. Und wir haben jetzt gerade eine Diskussion bei Twitter oder wo auch immer darum, was da in diesem Kiefer vor Ort Bucza passiert ist. So. Und klar, das ist besonders schlimm. Also vielleicht kommt man jetzt auch in so ein Relativierungsding. Es gibt so den Krieg, dann gibt es dann den besonders schlimmen Krieg.
Eigentlich das, was Herfried Münkler beschrieben hat, ich hatte den Ausschnitt vorgelesen. Posteroische Kriege sind keineswegs humanere Kriege. Im Gegenteil, sie sehen so aus, dass die Zivilbevölkerung terrorisiert wird. Und genau das haben wir jetzt da in Bildern zum Teil sehen können.
Und ich finde es absolut skurril, dass wir auf Twitter so einen, keine Ahnung, einen Monat lang so einen, ja die müssen sich auf jeden Fall verteidigen. Klar, kämpfen die Männer da für etwas und so weiter. Also wir haben es alles diskutiert. Und dass man jetzt plötzlich so eine Linie hat, über die man hinüber sieht und sagt, das geht aber zu weit. Ich bin ja für Krieg, aber nicht so. Und das muss man mit sich selber dann mal klären, diese Argumentation. Also wie man dieses Problem einfach für sich auflöst. Denn was auf Twitter da gerade passiert, an diesem Punkt finde ich nicht mehr nachvollziehbar. Also da kann ich mir das nicht mehr erklären.
Ja, die Antwort wäre kein Krieg. Und das ist ganz furchtbar. Ich muss auch, weil ich tatsächlich so ein paar Nachrichten bekommen habe, wie ich damit umgehe mit der Situation, weil wir nicht so persönlich reden. Ich kann sagen, ich vertiefe mich in Lektüren. Mir hat das Buch von Sandel das zu lesen. Oder auch diesen sehr drastischen Roman über die Vergewaltigung, in der Vertiefung, also sich zu konzentrieren auf einen Text und sich rauszuziehen, zum Beispiel aus Twitter, mehr geholfen als alles andere. Und auch lange Texte über den Krieg lesen, also den Text, über den ich sprechen will. Was machen da eigentlich Putins Eliten? Oder sind es überhaupt Putins Eliten? So etwas ist viel beruhigender und sinnvoller, als da bei Twitter den Diskurs mitzuverfolgen. Denn mitunter hat man den Eindruck, dass da jetzt Leute twittern, die sagen, jetzt haben wir schon Zero-Covid nicht bekommen. Jetzt möchte ich aber wenigstens einen dritten Weltkrieg haben, um das mal ganz überspitzt zu sagen. Ich halte das für alles, alles für sehr falsch und auch gefährlich. Und wir können aber ein bisschen beruhigt sein, glaube ich. Wenn wir das Buch von Sandel gelesen haben und wissen, der Kanzler liest es, hat es internalisiert. Das heißt vielleicht auch, dass das jemand ist, der ein bisschen gelassener oder sagen wir ein bisschen verantwortungsvoller als Kanzler agiert, als das einzelne Twitter-Account tun.
Ganz genau. Also auf in den Salon. Bis gleich oder bis später.